[Música]
el presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel
López Obrador cumplió cuatro años en el
poder y celebró marchando junto a sus
seguidores y defendiendo tanto su
gestión de gobierno como su propuesta de
reforma electoral
Cuba votó en sus elecciones municipales
para elegir a más de 12.000 delegados
mientras el gobierno defendió los
comicios diciendo que mostraban la
fortaleza electoral la abstención fue
una de las protagonistas
y hablando de protagonistas este lunes
en el mundial de
Qatar van a disputarse los partidos
entre Portugal y Uruguay además de
Brasil que se enfrenta a Suiza para
jugarse el paso a octavos de final si
alguno de los dos gana ampliamos desde
doha con nuestros empleados especiales
Bienvenidos a las noticias que Franz 24
le dedica a América y al mundial yo soy
María Clara calle y comenzamos hablando
de México porque el domingo el
presidente de Andrés Manuel López
Obrador cumplió cuatro años en el poder
y para celebrarlo organizó una marcha en
el centro de la capital Ciudad de México
esto de Cara a las elecciones generales
de 2024 y también en un momento en el
que el congreso debate la polémica
reforma electoral impulsada por el
mandatario Gabriel colchén nos da más
detalles una salida entre sus seguidores
para celebrar su cuarto año en el poder
el presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel
López Obrador estuvo este domingo en las
calles de la Ciudad de México la
manifestación organizada por el
presidente mismo reunió a miles de
personas en el centro de la ciudad
cuando él nos hasta en los momentos más
difíciles de la pandemia hemos
garantizado
que a la gente no le falte lo básico no
ha habido hambre ni por eso se ha
mantenido la paz y ha permanecido
encendida la llama de la esperanza según
varias encuestas el presidente tiene una
tasa de popularidad alta con un 60% de
aprobación sabemos que no han sido muy
fácil faltan muchos por hacer pero
estamos muy contentos de que el
presidente ha cumplido con la mayoría de
sus compromisos la marcha hace yo solo
unos días después de otra movilización
en la cual participaron miles de
opositores para protestar contra la
polémica propuesta de reforma electoral
en abril el presidente presentó un
proyecto de reforma del Instituto
Nacional electoral el órgano autónomo
que organiza las elecciones en México la
reforma que requiere el apoyo de al
menos dos tercios del parlamento podría
eliminar varias instituciones
importantes y concentrar la Organización
de las elecciones en manos del partido
gobernante
la oposición denuncia un riesgo para la
democracia y algunos Incluso acusan el
presidente de querer mantenerse en el
poder Aunque López Obrador prometió que
no se presentará a su reelección México
celebrará elecciones generales en 2024
según la Constitución el presidente
puede ejercer un solo mandato 1700
millones de dólares es lo que destinará
Canadá a su estrategia para
contrarrestar el poder de china en el
Indo Pacífico el país americano lanzó su
plan de 26 páginas en el que aspira a
fortalecer sus relaciones en la zona
donde hay 40 países por eso le apuestan
a abrir nuevos mercados de exportación a
la vez que respaldarán la seguridad de
Naciones como Japón y Corea del Sur ante
las amenazas de Corea del norte Sin
embargo Canadá explicó en el documento
que la cooperación con china es
necesaria para enfrentar las presiones
mundiales como el cambio climático la
salud global y la proliferación nuclear
más de 8 millones cubanos estaba
llamados a participar en las elecciones
municipales para elegir a más de 12.000
delegados sin embargo la votación del
domingo se dio en medio de una fuerte
Ascensión convocada por los opositores
del gobierno de Miguel Díaz a lo que la
autoridad electoral cubana respondió
extendiendo el horario de votación hasta
las 7 de la noche hora local veamos En
qué consisten los comicios
en Cuba también votan este domingo en
concreto para sus elecciones municipales
el presidente de Miguel Díaz canel
reivindicó la celebración de los
comicios el proceso electoral ratifica
que Cuba mantiene la estabilidad
política mantienen su estabilidad social
independientemente del primero de
recrudecimiento de la batalla económica
la batalla de asfixia económica que nos
están tratando de implantar para que la
población por el descontento por la
desesperanza por lo agobio de todas las
las carencias vayan al lado estallido
social que tiene el gobierno
imperial que es aplicar la lógica
imperialista en estas elecciones se
escogen los delegados que conforman las
asambleas municipales del poder popular
no pueden hacer campaña y las
nominaciones son en reuniones vecinales
donde se tienen cuenta méritos
personales y no posiciones políticas por
lo que no tienen que pertenecer al
partido comunista entre sus funciones la
gestión directa de problemas y quejas en
las comunidades además de proponer que
el 50% de los candidatos a las asambleas
provinciales y al parlamento elección
legislativa que tendrá lugar en 2023 es
importante muy importante porque así se
representa el pueblo en
la asamblea la oposición sin embargo
había pedido a la ciudadanía la
abstención denuncian que se les ha
impedido en gran medida participar en
unas elecciones marcadas por la grave
crisis económica que vive Cuba y
precisamente en medio de esta crisis
económica Cuba recibió un alivio pues
china acordó reestructurar la deuda que
tiene el país latinoamericano y
proporcionar nuevos créditos comerciales
y de inversión el ministro de economía
de Cuba Alejandro Gil agregó que el
gigante asiático además donó 100
millones de dólares para ayudar a la
isla a hacer frente a la escasez de
productos básicos y a la crisis
energética no se conoce el monto
específico de la deuda de los cubanos
con china sin embargo la isla dijo en
2019 que su de externa era de 19.600
millones de dólares
ahora pasamos a las noticias del mundial
de fútbol en Qatar este lunes habrá
partidos interesantes como Portugal
contra Uruguay o Brasil ante Suiza desde
doha nuestro enviado especial
juanjopiales nos da el panorama
termina la segunda fecha de la fase de
grupos de este mundial de Qatar 2022
tenemos actividad en el grupo G y el
grupo H por el grupo G Brasil se mide
contra se usa para poner a prueba su
favoritismo si en Neymar entraría
Rodrigo en su lugar además tampoco
estará Danilo en su lugar entraría Eder
militao además en el otro encuentro de
este grupo Serbia se mide contra
carmerún duelo de necesitados en este
partido ambas elecciones comenzaron con
derrotas soldadura en esta cita
mundialista y una nueva derrota los
pondría casi que fuera de esta copa
mundo conserve todavía no sabemos si
finalmente veremos tanto a blackovich
como a microbich como inicialistas en
ese encuentro en el otro grupo del día
que ese grupo H También tenemos
actividad de un equipo latinoamericano
hablamos de Uruguay que se mide contra
Portugal en el duero que va a cerrar la
jornada de este lunes se habla de
cambios en la médular de los charrúas
entrarían ya sea Jordan de arrascaeta o
Nicolás de la cruz para este partido
crucial contra Portugal en el que no
estará con la selección luza Danilo
Pereira lesionado se especula con que
podría ser Pepe mientras que en el otro
partido que tenemos por este grupo será
Corea del Sur quién se mira contra gana
otra de las caras del mundial de Qatar
son los testimonios de víctimas de
trabajo forzado durante la construcción
de los estadios nepal Calcula que 1800
de su ciudadanos murieron trabajando en
Qatar mientras una investigación del
periódico de Guardian estima que al
menos 6.500 trabajadores migrantes
fallecieron en condiciones de esclavitud
en katmandú la capital de nepal una
víctima de trabajo forzoso del mundial
da su testimonio
este era mi permiso de trabajo para
acatar camille serpa trabajo durante más
de un año en la construcción del metro
en ocasiones tuve que trabajar a 45 e
incluso 55 grados centígrados teníamos
que trabajar incluso cuando estábamos
enfermos los trabajadores no
cualificados los nepalíes dicen que son
los más maltratados en las obras
a 3000 kilómetros de nepal en doha uno
de nuestros periodistas fue invitado a
visitar un campamento de trabajadores
llevo aquí desde 2016 y estamos en 2022
puedo decir que hay muchas mejoras en
materia de derechos humanos y derechos
laborales
según the Guardian al menos 6.500
trabajadores migrantes han muerto en
Qatar desde el inicio de las obras las
autoridades cataríes dicen que solo han
contabilizado 37 y cuántos nepalíes
en 2015 un equipo de fans televisión
filmó estas imágenes en el aeropuerto de
katmandú cada semana aterrizaban aviones
procedentes de Qatar con los restos de
los trabajadores nepalíes a bordo en el
sur del país en la región más pobre de
nepal hay decenas de familias
desconsoladas
mi hermana yandra perdió a su marido en
2019 diez meses después de su llegada a
Qatar El joven de 27 años era trabajador
de la construcción en un estadio
su certificado de defunción dice que
murió de causas naturales pero la viuda
nunca recibió un certificado de autopsia
no entiendo mi marido era fuerte a Quién
nepal construyó casas según las
autoridades nepalíes 180 de sus
nacionales han muerto cada año en Qatar
desde que se concedió la copa del mundo
y así terminamos las noticias por ahora
pero los invitamos a que sigan
conectados con nuestra señal y con
nuestra página web France 24.com
[Música]